[Music]
Jordan said that I don't I wanted to
defend this until I lost it I didn't
want to retire having a championship and
then sorry there's two things I don't
believe in the duck yeah fair enough I
do not believe that Jordan this
unstoppable force there's literally
nothing that can get in his way he will
do whatever it takes
whenever it takes it does not matter I
do not believe that a short fat egg of a
human being could just pick know any big
yes sir I if Jordan really wanted that
seventh try I think that he could have
went right to Ryan's old egg bring back
Phil bring back Scotty payam do one year
like short money and give a long term
something like that you can trade I mean
has trade value Rodman give me one more
year I think Jordan could have made that
happen
but he didn't try to make it happen and
that's on [ __ ] Jordan hmm I watched
it and I was skeptical and now we're
hopping really far ahead but I was like
yeah I don't know that I fully buy your
explanation that you want it more than
anybody on earth has ever wanted it
Jordan is a [ __ ] singular human being
maybe in history yeah and you're not
willing to go over Jerry Krause his head
and go straight to Reinsdorf and say
look let me try to get Phil let me try
to use Scott even let me try to work
this out you didn't talk everybody else
talking [ __ ] them having a one-on-one
I'll make this happen and rise over to
listen there's so much there are so many
hundreds of millions of dollars you can
make off a bad dynasty that's the other
thing about Reinsdorf it's like one more
year you're making so much money it
justifies whatever luxury taxes you have
to pay
there was a luxury tax back then there
was a hard cap maybe no yeah but they
had the soft camp they had a Larry Bird
exception so you could have signed the
luxury tax was like a year or two later
I think okay and there might have been
some strike [ __ ] also it's a [ __ ]
strike-shortened season but back back up
back up to the bird rules right Larry
Bird exception if a players played on
your team for more than three years I
think right you can sign them and then
it doesn't count against your salary cap
and how many players can you do that
with I don't know if there's a limit I
think you don't know Jordan and Pippen
and maybe Rodman she could have done it
yeah
again we don't know for certain but uh
and maybe we should look at
I think that I just think that the main
reason that were linked that he made it
look like he was so furious that they
didn't have a seventh shot and maybe
he's furious and now because he didn't
put his foot down about it but Jordan
was the single most powerful person in
sports and if he wanted he could have
switched that up now I've spoken to my
buddies around the league and he goes
and they said that like there's a weird
thing that happens with players even
like the most elite players they fall in
line and his take was you're so used to
having coaches that you listen to what
they say throughout your entire life
it's just part of the dynamics and
sports that you just kind of respect
authority and I'm like no that's not
true think about you know guys like Kobe
you guys like Bron this at the other he
goes yeah they don't but they do so it's
like a guy like LeBron didn't even know
that certain guys were getting signed
right like I think bran found out that
who's the big bomb seven footer there's
always getting Texas [ __ ] that the
Lakers signed all weekend texts Tex tech
technical fouls Oh Oh Dwight Howard no
he just tore his Achilles Oh
boogy cousin's bogey yeah yeah like I
think he didn't even know the certain
people got silent he has maybe the most
control of a franchise right for most
people so I was like he's like they just
kind of fall in line granted they are
like the kings of the castle but it
doesn't exactly affect upper management
that's what you say I didn't personally
buy it to his point though that's now it
still happens a little bit and 25 years
ago maybe having more meat in there was
no real precedent for giving players all
the power yeah I just yeah I was looking
at him like you coulda got a 70 you
don't publicly all you got to do is say
once publicly you go one interview you
know the news guys somebody comes up to
you the microphone just like you know
what I want to come back for another
year the only way I'll do it is if we
get all these players back as well
Bulls make it happen the franchise would
implode if you did not make it employs
that I take I put all the blame on Phil
ok I do percent of the blame on Phil
okay I hate when Jordan was watching
that clip of the owner saying like
God feels like we can run it back one
more time and Phil actually turns down
he's like and they go I could play fair
to Jerry if we do this and they don't
play Jordan a clip of Phil saying Jerry
came to me and I said I don't know I
don't think it's fair that looked like
Jordan was seeing that for the first
time yeah and I bet you if Phil would
have been like okay let's do it one more
time
Jordan would've came back everybody
woulda came back I've really n like you
said I think Jordan fell in line and if
my leaders not coming back yeah I'm not
coming back but he got a leader to come
back one more year
I feel wasn't supposed to come back I
don't know you know what I'm saying
before um there's actually a seven yeah
I don't think Phil told anybody else
that hey they gave me the option to come
back again I think Phil wanted a break
and I I think this is really interesting
looking to fill because you can see how
much of a hippie is like even when they
celebrate like everybody's going crazy
and he's just kind of like whoa
scooby-doo it's really crazy so I loved
everything he said to join in that
moment it was also beautiful to watch
that was all you like that's why he's
Phil but didn't he seem so and I hate to
use the word Zen but like didn't he seem
so Zen even in that moment like yeah
smiling like a Buddha would smile at the
championship he's not jumping up down
screaming doing backflips like everybody
else cool he looks like he's on an acid
trip like he's just like he's a unique
phase and unique figure I think that
it's Jerry Krause his job to get Phil to
want to come back clearly Krause's ego
gets the best of him here right yeah
that's fair I'll even push back on what
I said earlier which was he was the
great a bubble I still think he's
incredibly talented constructing that
team but his ego got in the way
that being said he's justified it after
the fact Kraus
by breaking up team by saying that
everybody got old yeah and he put out
this article that's on NBC Sports it's
an excerpt from his memoir that's still
that's right his memoirs gonna come out
and it's really cool of his uh his wife
who's still alive she's been asked about
this documentary the last day of
documentary she's like he has a book
coming out I'm gonna let him have the
final word I'm not gonna say anything
that's pretty dope that's dumb yeah
and he basically goes through all the
decisions that were made right yeah they
did like these intense medical
evaluations of all the players yeah
and obviously they thought Michael could
still play but they're like luc longley
is about to break down rodman we don't
think has anymore and i'm Pippins back
is [ __ ] up and he's gonna ask for too
much money steve kerr and judge bushel
are gonna get bigger offers so we just
couldn't afford to bring the team back
together now who cares if you could
afford to look he justifies it by saying
look what happened to Luc Longley went
to Phoenix he kind of struggled with his
ankles he ended up on the Knicks but he
just fell apart then they go he says we
did Scotty a favor basically he really
did he goes we did a sign-and-trade for
Scotty but he can make more money we
made 20 million more and I think the
reason you can make more is because of
Larry Bird exception which proves they
could have signed because what they do
is they sign Scottie Pippin to a big
deal
it doesn't [ __ ] with the cat because you
can sign them or whatever I think it's
the Larry Bird exception and then you
you trade him right right maybe yeah
maybe or maybe it was one of those like
you can sign a longer oh yeah that's
what he said otherwise players to say
but uh and then you know he's like
everybody worried Rodman's partying and
caught up to him Rodman played thirty
five more games for the Lakers yeah that
was it and then so so he has and then he
they say he says about Michael he's like
Michael like severed a tendon in his
shooting his pointer fingers got a
shooting hand and he wouldn't been be
able to play the entire season because
of that yeah now he did that in the
summer with like some cigar cutter or
some [ __ ] so he's he's basically going
look we made the right decision all the
players fell apart Michael couldn't even
play what the [ __ ] do you want from us
that being said everything could have
completely changed if they knew they're
coming back to do a seventh season maybe
luc longley takes care of his body in
the offseason
maybe Rodman goes I'm actually gonna
play because these aren't going to be
meaningless games you know if it's the
right decision and you're a good GM you
would think you would have made the
playoffs in the next ten years or fire
how long did it go probably to like
Derrick who's there right yeah I mean I
don't I'm sure they I don't remember a
competitive team from them until Derrick
Rose yeah yeah that was the gap and
that's not Gerry Krause's rebuild that
did that it's just so interesting like
so it's so interesting like do you think
Phil thought this choice came to me do
you think Phil after six was like I'm
exhausted also I don't know how to
motivate them anymore I used everything
I had on the last dance what do I say
the last dance part too what's the
[ __ ] what's the motivation here I
don't have
I think phil was exhausted yeah I think
this is like it was really difficult for
Phil like emotionally difficult holding
all this together like think about it
she's me
Phil's and and Michael says it in the
documentary I mean everybody says it by
Phil but Phil's ability to manage egos
is what made him so great and get
everybody to be part of the team and
like sacrifice for the team I think
Michael says that yeah right handling
all those players and these are a lot of
egos like handling Pippins ego handling
Jordan handling the way Jordan treated
the players like yeah Jordan's gonna
berate you Phil's got to build you back
up so you don't lose all your confidence
yeah like handling that [ __ ]
situation dude that has got to be
exhausting it's like III have an
experience this I've been very [ __ ]
lucky but like you know there sometimes
kids that play like this kind of almost
referee role with their parents yeah
they're like parents are fighting all
the time and they're kind of like
managing that relationship in real time
sometimes they're even divorced and
they're constantly managing that
relationship and like you see the
[ __ ] cost that that has on like a kid
it's like emotionally taxing it's like
had your mom crying or your dad like
furious or Sarah
imagine doing that for [ __ ] six
championships with Michael Jordan oh my
and his E I mean the greatest player of
all times ego and not knowing every
practice is he gonna punch somebody what
the [ __ ] is that takes some [ __ ] time
do this my great point I think he was
truly exhausted yeah I think Jordan
could have convinced him to come back
because Jordan can convince anybody but
I don't think that he was upset in the
least yeah he doesn't sound like he said
I didn't want to come back boom I
thought it wouldn't be fair to Jerry I
don't believe you really think he blames
Jerry to be honest yeah because he
didn't what I think he use that as a but
I think he didn't think they could win
again oh that's what I think then I
think that celebration at the last one
was shocked because he did we actually
did one and you saw the breakdown like
Scotty's back to start a fall apart yeah
like Phil and that's that thought hit me
too this is actually crazy MJ when he
came back the second time didn't miss a
single game those three years
which is insane but like unbeliev you
think about their run and there's no
playoff series where they're like yo we
had a big injury to this guy we had to
overcome and you see that all the time
now the Warriors last year Kevin Durant
goes down the finals LeBron a few years
ago Kyrie and Kevin Love are out for the
playoffs and that just happens it
happens almost every year never happened
to the Bulls this is the first time I
was like oh he's hobbled yeah and then
before that the last time I Scottie
Pippen got migraines in game 7 hmm
against Detroit yo can we talk about
that a little bit like Pippins legacy
took a [ __ ] hit like if Pippen his
entire career has sacrificed for Jordan
to achieve what he needed to achieve
that continued in his day yeah yeah yeah
right like because in order for Jordans
greatness to show game 5 Pippen needs to
be this focal point with another back
injury or I'm gonna sit out in the
playoffs because I didn't get to take
the last shot or I'm gonna have a
contract dispute and get my surgery in
the fall like he got destroyed in this a
try they tried to help him out I was
noticing in this portrayal of game 6
where they had the trainer because
Jordan pry didn't say [ __ ] not but they
had the trainer being like every anybody
who questioned Scottie Pippen's heart is
out of his mind
yeah and the trainer huh physically he
like medically knows what's going on
with this guy
[Applause]